with every choice and action a timeline
of one's life is drawn forward
and for every possible choice and action
that one could make but doesn't
another possible world another possible
self another possible timeline
unfolds in a separate direction that one
can never know
there are nearly an infinite number of
ways for how frank's life could have
gone
many of which never went at all but one
in particular
went like this frank worked basically
his whole life in pursuit of one thing
what started as just a youthful
attraction mostly nothing more than a
seed of innocent curiosity and seeking
of identity
grew more and more with time into the
central focus of his life
in general very few youthful interests
remain steady and properly held together
through the storm of aging into
adulthood but for frank
painting did born with a congenital limb
length discrepancy
as a child frank's left leg was about
two and a half inches longer than his
right
more or less condemning him to a
lifelong limp that would only really
improve
following several surgeries once he was
older because of his condition he was
unable to participate in the more
traditional physical activities that a
young boy might otherwise be compelled
towards
moreover throughout his early childhood
he was often ridiculed or ignored by
many of his peers because of his limp
and was a rather isolated and sad child
art was the perfect outlet for frank
where mostly everything came together
for him
throughout high school frank took as
many art classes as he could
and unlike most of his other classes he
took the ones he did seriously
he spent much of his time outside of
school working and learning about art as
well
studying from the greats and developing
his own unique understanding
preference and style following high
school he went to college at the
university of pittsburgh and majored in
studio arts
frank was a slightly below average
student in high school and mostly stayed
the same in college
his focus and academic efforts were
fairly concentrated towards his art
courses
and his own personal art projects
however even despite his hyper-focused
efforts
his art seemed to remain relatively
average as well his work was strange
but not in a way that seemed to
translate very well generally
in college he was one of the better ones
in most of his low-level
classes but only one of the average ones
amongst the better ones
and in some of his higher level classes
he was even told by a couple professors
on multiple occasions
that his work was unsatisfactory lacking
in clear method
and technical understanding and too
focused on concept rather than
arrangement and execution
he barely made it by with low seas and
two senior level studio art classes
despite how good he was or wasn't though
frank felt this hunch that he was or
would be
perhaps it was more of a desire than a
hunch but it was no less a sense of
something
a sense that he had something in it a
tethering to his being that felt almost
divinely facilitated
he couldn't help but become addicted to
the feeling that art and painting gave
him
it was both an escape and entrance to
himself this addiction formed a
continued
and for the time being unshakable
obsession and dedication towards art
this obsession was relatively benign
during high school and for the most part
during college as well
however as he aged through out of and
beyond college
his dedication mostly remained but its
value only seemed to wane
by his early 30s frank had tried for
over a decade to make a name and career
for himself in the art world
he tried relentlessly making great
sacrifices in his life otherwise
he moved to certain areas took and quit
certain jobs
started and ended friendships and
relationships let go of opportunities
all for the purpose of pursuing his art
as much and as well as he could
despite his efforts though he had still
by this point found no real success
by most standards he seemed to lack a
technical ability that could fit
commercial work
and even in the more core art scenes his
work mostly didn't seem to fit either
on a variety of occasions some of his
work was accepted into small
local underground type galleries and
exhibitions
but these would do very little for him
in his career and worse yet
even at this level his work was often
criticized by peers
and critics of the art community some of
which described his work as tasteless
crude or quote not art those who did
like his work though
seemed to like it a lot ultimately frank
was stubborn
he had the sort of spirit of obsession
that couldn't easily be beaten out of
him
not to say that life wasn't trying
throughout this time he in fact teetered
back and forth between quitting and
continuing
constantly almost letting the fire burn
out but then saving it upon the final
embers
assisted by any puffs of positive
feedback he might receive
he was always a man of full commitment
so he was either going to try all
in or not at all as a result though
his continued dedication posed a variety
of challenges on his life
by this point frank lacked any real
experience or interest in much of
anything other than art
and so he mostly found himself stuck
with jobs that were
for all intents and purposes rather
horrible tedious
and low paying a variety of the sort of
stockroom data entry or office temp type
jobs
that can pull the soul from your skull
if you aren't careful
but he kept his head down tried his best
and did what he had to do to get by
and focus on his art as much as he could
throughout his mid-twenties and early
thirties
frank had very little money and a lot of
stress he often found himself struggling
to make ends meet and moreover
he often fell into great pits of
depression and drunken spirals of
disarray over his lack of success
and the life that he had found himself
in ultimately though
wise or unwise he continued to stay in
return to painting and art
as a central focus during this time as
frank aged into his later mid-thirties
at a certain point he became considered
by many standards
that of a failure his friends and family
strangers and women he would meet all
thought he was both foolish and
borderline insane
to still be pursuing what seemed like
mostly a lost cause
his aging mother who always envisioned a
prosperous and successful son
worried about frank in part because she
worried about his well-being
but mostly because she hated how he
reflected on her and the family
both frank's mother and father had and
continued to cringe
every time they were asked about frank
at family parties gatherings with
friends
or work-related events they hated
exposing the shortcomings of their son
because it felt as though it exposed
their own and so they would often
embellish or make up stories to aid in
how frank came off
they never understood what he was doing
and why the art seemed like nonsense to
them
and the general opinion of the public
seemed to agree they always told frank
that he should go into something more
viable
like marketing when they would
occasionally talk frank's father would
say things like
after a certain amount of time it's
either a hobby or nothing frank that
time is long coming gone
or the definition of insanity is doing
the same thing over and over and
expecting different results
frank would hear any and all of the
variety of cliches that could be used
against him
but for every cliche that could be used
against him frank could think of an
equal amount that could be used in favor
of him
ultimately though at a certain point
frank didn't know where that put him
he was nearly broke living on barely
anything unable to start and support a
family even if he wanted to
disapproved by the family he had and
disliked or unknown by most of his peers
he felt weak and incompetent beaten down
by the arbitrary game of life he
couldn't seem to get a good hand in
the later he went into his thirties it
only continued to become harder and
harder to reconcile the difference
between the world's perception of him
and his own he didn't necessarily care
how he was seen by others
but he was by now having a nearly
impossible time not seeing himself
mostly the same
the world's perception of him creeped
further and further inside his own skull
after enough failure a man comes to the
point where he has to decide whether or
not he himself
believes he in fact might be one
one night in the last year of his 30s
frank felt a strange pain in the back of
his neck
it wasn't a normal pain that he might
otherwise feel from horrible sleep or
stress
but an extremely tight and vicious pain
that he had never felt before
it was within bearable limits though and
it mostly subsided after a few minutes
so he didn't think much of it but then
over the next couple days
it happened again and again seemingly
worse each time
expanding into his head and bringing
with it a nausea and feeling of
disorientation that was impossible to
ignore
what was weird is that frank's doctor
couldn't figure out what was wrong
he had frank undergo several different
tests but there appeared to be no sign
of any ailment
internal physical injury malformation or
otherwise
his doctor essentially said that if
frank wasn't experiencing any symptoms
he would have given him a clean bill of
health he prescribed frank the migraine
medication
alma triptan and told him to notify him
if things got any worse
as days progressed frank became more and
more ill
losing energy exhibiting unusual
behaviors and falling into what seemed
like constant discomfort and pain
frank promptly contacted his doctor
again who then referred him to several
specialists
who he scheduled appointments with the
following week on the sunday of that
weekend
frank was found dead in his apartment he
was 39.
following his death an autopsy revealed
a tiny edema
or swelling in the frontal lobe of his
brain which would have likely caused a
slow disruption of the blood flow until
eventually it built up
into presumably a stroke it was too tiny
to be noticed
until it was too late not to be
frank died essentially with nothing to
show for his life in terms of
traditional success
whether or not that matters at all is
subsequent to the fact that he died
without ever accomplishing what he
dedicated his life to
and believed his life to be for he died
without ever feeling like he was who he
thought he was
or could be he died in the eyes of
everyone who knew him
including himself a failure however
perhaps far
far sadder than all of that is what
frank didn't know
and now could never know in life for
every choice and action
a timeline of oneself is drawn forward
and for every possible choice and action
that one could make but doesn't
another possible world another possible
self another possible timeline unfolds
in a separate direction that one can
never know
there are nearly an infinite number of
ways for how frank's life could have
gone
many of which never went at all but one
in particular
went exactly the same except one thing
on one night a couple weeks prior to the
day he died frank decided to start a new
art piece
instead of going to a bar and because he
didn't go to the bar
he didn't get drunk and because he
didn't get drunk he never drunkenly fell
forward and hit his head on the corner
of the lower section of a stop sign
while trying to catch a cab in a mild
blackout that he wouldn't remember the
next day
because he never sustained this
seemingly mild forgotten and hangover
concealed head injury
his brain never developed a swelling and
thus he never died at age 39
instead he kept on living normally and
kept on working
on that new art piece and about seven
months later
that piece got noticed by an art dealer
who happened to be visiting and scanning
local galleries
who told frank that the piece had a
standout raw quality that was exactly
what he was looking for
the dealer went on to eventually sell
that art piece for seventeen thousand
dollars
ultimately igniting frank's career
working with the art dealer over the
following several years
by around 43 years old frank would go on
to become world famous in the art world
and then eventually famous in the world
at large
his career would blossom more and more
allowing him to work full time
all in on his art and make more than a
comfortable living doing so
both during and after his lifetime he
would be thought of as a leading figure
of his generation
regarded for being significantly ahead
of his time and uniquely distinct from
any other art movements and styles
his innovative work would be mimicked by
artists to come and the rippling effects
of his conceptual style
provoked artistic and cultural movements
that reverberated into the future
indefinitely
frank was right either in the fact that
he was built to be a successful artist
or in the fact that he would eventually
build himself into one
but in the version of the world that he
knew and the version that came true
he was dead he not only died before he
knew that his work went on to be of
great success
but died before his work ever did in
truth there are a lot of frank's
timelines that wouldn't have gone that
way
ones where he didn't die early but he
was dead wrong about his abilities
nonetheless
but one never knows which timeline
they're on and one never knows
how close they are to success on the one
they are
and the world does not and can never
know those who gave up slightly too soon
to find out
you